hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and I am just checking in on you
I'm not yelling it I'm in Houston right
now and I have got a show here in a
couple of hours and you know bill is I
am in an advanced age at this point you
know this how old I am I now qualify for
something I never heard of before it's
called a a a P AARP
I don't know what it does it's for old
guys like me we're not 65 we're 50 and
evidently I can now go to the movies for
8 bucks
I probably get a free side of Metamucil
you know maybe a little bend to Pat
bengay when I walk out but I'm psyched
so yeah don't let anybody ever tell you
that gettin old [ __ ] sucks okay yeah
it does your body breaks down eventually
you take a dirt nap who's kidding who
you know you [ __ ] surrounded by loved
ones as you're laying there everybody's
bottom lip quivering did you just sit
there was IA good person was there good
person right yeah that sucks but there's
a lot of [ __ ] that balances it off all
right $8 tickets to movies BAM talking
[ __ ] to somebody in their 20s you know
like you're a badass but you're too old
for them to [ __ ] with you so you look
tough right in front of your 50 year old
wife boom I mean that's pretty much the
extent of it I haven't really I'm new to
this being [ __ ] over the hill here
but you know getting to wear a stupid
hat right one of those [ __ ] old man
coats I can't [ __ ] I mean it's it's
Ellie I can't wait but uh I'm going to
enjoy it anyways before we get started I
have a couple things to promote Oh rough
and rowdy brawl August 5th
the people over there were nice enough
el pres Dave Portnoy was nice enough to
invite me back and of course I jumped at
the chance I had such a great time the
last time when we were in [ __ ]
Charlotte it's so cool and I will show
up to these things as long as they have
me because it's it's ridiculously fun so
it's gonna be in Youngstown Ohio alright
kids come out of the womb swinging
alright when the doctor hits the baby on
the ass in Youngstown he's wearing
headgear that's all I'm saying in a
mouthpiece alright bill we get it that
tough alright
who knows I don't know what their deal
is they I don't know why they're so
tough there I imagine you know I think
each little pool of people you know
starts off with it with a couple of Adam
and Eve's right and they bang and then
whatever if they're into books then you
get like Seattle you know but if they
got hammered and they beat the [ __ ] out
of each other yeah you get Youngstown I
haven't researched any of this but I
don't know what all I know is I'm not
looking anybody in the eye when I get
there cuz I don't I don't need to be
clocked by [ __ ] Kelly Pavlik third
cousin but anyway so I got to do a gig
I'm gonna do a gig right before I get
there I'm gonna be in Rochester New York
alright I believe home a Steve Gadd
childhood home I remember he was I
remember that I used to watch that
instructional DVD that he had a zillion
times up close and he would talk about
how he got his hands together playing in
the Rochester Crusaders it was a drum
corps I know crazy information but
whatever it's in my head I got to get it
out so that will be on August 4th August
5th I'll be driving down to Youngstown
for rough and rowdy so go too rough and
rowdy brawl com2 get your tickets to
stream it whatever you gotta do it's
gonna be [ __ ] awesome and I've
already seen some of the highlights so I
should really retweet some of the some
of the guys they got some Pittsburgh
Cleveland guys no love lost there with
all the Steelers trophies and
Cleveland's barren shelf because
reason they don't count NFL titles which
Cleveland won I think in 65 but you know
as far as franchises go that went out to
[ __ ] Baltimore Baltimore scarface
reference anywho I'm here in Houston
Texas oh my god I thought it was gonna
be [ __ ] brutally hot I was like I was
almost ready to call my agent and be
like how many [ __ ] years have you
been in this business slash how many
years have you been booking me that you
would book a bald redheaded male that
qualifies for AARP in Houston Texas in
[ __ ] July but um we were coming in
for Elena and I was looking out the
window and all the you know fields that
I saw were green so I was like all right
maybe they get in some rain I don't know
but it's not that bad down here the bad
thing is is I forgot my show shoes you
know for those of you not in show
business you have your shoes that you
walk around in your shoes your workout
in or whatever all right this is very
first world here okay for those those of
you listening in lesser countries okay
we are so privileged here that we have
shoes for different events I need to
work out right I'm gonna [ __ ] wear
these shoes I'm gonna go I don't know go
run some errands oh I think I'll grab
those and then you got to put on a show
and dance like a monkey yeah these other
[ __ ] shows now I know other people
other towns you know countries I should
say you know you got one pair of shoes
if you're lucky right you and 18 other
people jump on a [ __ ] moped with 37
boxes and somehow you don't tip over and
you go down the street making [ __ ]
Instagram videos I see you out there
I see you out there all the time I don't
know how you do it
is it like Youngstown we just grew up
fighting you guys just grow up [ __ ]
stack and [ __ ] up until it makes no
sense
and somehow they stay upright everybody
always watches [ __ ] Evel Knievel
jumping over the busses with with a
motorcycle that
probably weighed like four to five
hundred thousand [ __ ] pounds you know
as great as that is as impressive as
that is you know to drive down the
street with all your personal belongings
your wife and all of your kids with that
much to lose I don't think Evel Knievel
can touch that you know because if he
wiped out he died that was it he didn't
lose [ __ ] everything and all this
clothes all right so that's one to grow
on
next time they say Evel Knievel is is is
the grandfather of [ __ ] the x-games
all right you know there's always
somebody else everybody talks about
Edison there's always a Tesla sorry what
do you want from me I gotta fill up a
[ __ ] half-hour here I'm waiting for
my salad with the protein coming I've
been doing real well with the whole
eating and everything and I actually got
in contact with a nutritionist I took a
long pause there for all you guys be
like you get Botox you [ __ ] freckled
[ __ ] huh you're gonna find some ginger
cat and skinned it and put the [ __ ]
hair on top of your head well maybe I
will that makes me feel better about
myself [ __ ] that cat never been a cat
person right you know why they have such
attitudes is because they're allowed to
[ __ ] in the house and then they think
you're on the same level and then
they're faster than you and then it's
over
then you can you know you can instill
like [ __ ] martial law with the water
spray bottle you don't want to [ __ ]
do that although I would enjoy doing
that I would actually you know if I
wasn't in this business I would do that
as a job because I don't like cats I
respect them I do but I would get a lot
of enjoyment spring water it cats that
jump on the back of couches is that
actually a career can you do that is
that how my life's gonna end wait a
minute
is that what's gonna happen me I'm gonna
die alone with like a cat you know have
a cigar
a little glass of [ __ ] whiskey or
something
and I'll just be sitting there in my
rocking chair I'll have all these all
these [ __ ] cats so I you know that'll
be like my [ __ ] PlayStation 19 right
because I you know I wouldn't have saved
my money I'll have all these [ __ ]
cats and then I'll just be spraying I'm
just cackling laughing until I keel over
like Brando and [ __ ] The Godfather
Jesus bill you really but I know I don't
know what it is you know I was doing so
well with my anger and just late I just
[ __ ] I just been losing it lately
[ __ ] losing it I don't know I think I
need to let it out it's kind of like
boozing it's like if I don't do it then
it just builds up I went online
yesterday looking up like what do you
what'd you call that uh it's not a fifth
of Jack down since it's the small of us
the little brother there that one that's
always been my favorite if you're just
gonna get [ __ ] hammered you get that
size of it right I was just talking to
Nate Craig who's gonna be with me this
weekend crushing it in front of me I was
saying I like that size you pour it over
on on the rocks
you don't get like there's no guilt that
you're wasting this booze that's been in
a barrel for [ __ ] I don't know since
Nixon was in office and you just sitting
there getting shit-faced watching a
baseball game it's you know it's Jack
Daniels this is plenty of it right and
then when you finish the bottle you get
like a sense of accomplishment so that's
all that not boozing does for me it just
makes me well makes me want to booze
more and I think like not flipping out
is the same thing all right now for
those of you new to the podcasts if
you're questioning did he just justify
not controlling his emotions and his
drinking problem yes I did yes I did and
thank you for noticing I don't have a
[ __ ] drinking problem I drink just
fine what I have is a drinking buddy
problem I can't seem to get anybody I
can [ __ ] drink with they ain't gonna
be sitting there counting my [ __ ]
drinks alright now we both went to
public schools we can both count up to
20 you ain't pressing me all right you
want impress me by
[ __ ] round quick reminded me that I
drove tonight the [ __ ] could [ __ ]
drive that car in my [ __ ] sleep I'll
back it on home keep [ __ ] talking
that's my man or alcoholic is a [ __ ]
redneck anyway so shout-out to Chris
Hardwick
congratulations they investigated and
they found out what most of us already
knew you're a good guy and it was nice
to see one of those ones that seemed
really sort of [ __ ] frivolous be
investigated thoroughly according to CNN
Entertainment and you know that's uh
that that was that needed to [ __ ]
happen
because you know that homie to movement
was supposed to be for people that were
like victims it wasn't supposed to be
you know something to be used to get
back at somebody you know I don't know I
I shouldn't I guess allegedly whatever
the [ __ ] you're supposed to say but it
was nice to see that AMC took the time
to investigate it saw that nothing
happened they were satisfied with it and
they brought the guy back there you go
there you go I hope that this is like
you know cuz it kind of needed that good
knit there was the initial [ __ ] you
know because nobody listened to women so
then just think there was just this
floodgate a [ __ ] anger you had to
ride through it and just you knew
eventually somebody who didn't do [ __ ]
was gonna go down so it's it's it's nice
to see that they they rectified that
situation did I just get myself in
trouble by saying rectified is that too
much like rectal then I just I just
advocate something it's just a strange
type you know um anyways plowing ahead
here yes oh I forgot my goddamn show
shoes alright um you know I'm becoming
Billy minimalist but not not on this
level like I like to wear a nice pair of
[ __ ] sneakers or shoes when I do my
shows and I don't have them but I
I had just had my [ __ ] workout
sneakers so I'm gonna go out there look
in shop from the ankles up and then I'm
gonna have these big clunky [ __ ] 50
year old white guy my feet hurts
sometimes sneakers on so you know I give
it about seven minutes before somebody
heckles me well now that I put it out
there someone's gonna do it and think
they're original or maybe a stair way of
saying that they listen to the podcast I
don't know but I'm gonna beat all of you
because I'm just gonna come out and
address it anyway she what they look
like they actually they don't even look
like men's sneakers you know those
[ __ ] sneakers that like old lady was
old ladies with big feet get you know
you see him on the bus they just have
like you see him the cute little old
ladies and they just have these giant
[ __ ] sneakers over their feet you
know what I mean that's what they look
like no they're not all white Reeboks
from the late 80s anyway so I am really
looking forward to I got two days here
in Houston and then I got one in Dallas
Houston's gonna be fun Dallas is gonna
be awesome but it's gonna be a little
sad because this is my first time going
to Dallas and with Vinnie Paul not being
around anymore and he was a big comedy
fan and he was somebody that I always
made sure I reached out to and I had a
50/50 chance cuz he also lived in Vegas
that he was going to be in town but yeah
that's gonna suck I was just talking to
a buddy of mine who was hanging out with
Vinnie just a few days before he passed
and he was saying he used to always
quote comedians bits and he would always
like mess him up he was just the funnest
[ __ ] guy ever man god damn it anyway
so I'll be going up there and in my mind
will be dedicating my show to him so
that means I have to go hard but by the
way I don't know how I missed all of
this Pantera [ __ ] now that I'm like
totally [ __ ] into them and like trying
to play drums along to their amazing
music and somebody sent me the the
official video tumblr
which I never saw and what I love is
they spend enough time on Vinnie that I
saw this [ __ ] that I was playing wrong
as far as uh whatever just you know the
two opening crashes like I didn't know
he had like four crashes two on each
side and then there was another part I
thought he was playing eighths me was
playing sixteenth pretty [ __ ] cool
you don't get that a lot in music videos
music videos usually barely shows the
drummer and when they do they have the
snare when he's hitting the snare he or
she's hitting the snare it's on the one
in three and the bass the bass drums on
two and four I cannot tell you how many
[ __ ] times they do that it's like are
you even listening to the music right
now you're hearing the crack of the
snare and you got him [ __ ] you're
lining up the video and he's hitting the
[ __ ] bass drum if anything and the
music videos on would drove me more nuts
there wasn't anything it was that that
they would never [ __ ] show the
drummer and when they did they it was
just like they didn't give a [ __ ] I
think they just looked at the right hand
to just line up the music and that was
it and then they didn't see what else do
we was [ __ ] the amount of times they
cut to it like this singer he's singing
some part and you see the drummer
playing the fill that you don't even
hear or you hear a fill and the guys
just playing the beat it just you know
oh the [ __ ] guitarist does something
oh Jesus Christ let's make sure we
[ __ ] line that up note for note
the singer pay attendees like [ __ ] the
drummer so anyways it's a great video
because they did not do that in that
video sorry look at me getting all
worked up over nothing
so anyways a friend of mine got me in
touch with the nutritionist this is not
code named for a drug dealer
somebody just knock on my door no no
Jesus hang on a second anyways so uh I
got this [ __ ] nutritionist because I
want to learn I want to learn how to eat
well you know what I mean I don't want
just be this guy like hey man
I'm gonna [ __ ] cut this out and I'm
gonna start [ __ ] doing that you know
like I mentioned before like how many
that like the amount of fat [ __ ]
vegans
I'm talking like back fat I'm not just
saying they got a little pooch or
something like that I'm just talking
about like you know just looking at
people like you just look at them like
you you look like you're not healthy and
they'll be like oh I'm a vegetarian or
I'm [ __ ] vegan and all of that so
anyways like I mentioned I bring the
[ __ ] food tray over here there's like
there's so much [ __ ] like
misinformation I don't know how to I
don't know how to sift through it and I
don't want to become a vegetarian you
know what I mean but I also [ __ ] hate
working out you know what I mean so I
would like to [ __ ] just eat smarter
is what I'm trying to do you know now
that I'm on the [ __ ] Road this is
what always gets me you know I come in
I'm grumpy from a flight you know and
you look at the salads and when you're
in a [ __ ] bad mood and you're hungry
a salad never looks like the right
option does it it never does what do you
do yeah I'm gonna get a [ __ ] burger
and you're trying to say I want a side
salad and then the lady's like do you
want fries with that and then your head
going no bill don't do it any yeah yeah
[ __ ] it give me some goddamn fries
thirty you can order your food without
using that language I'd like to remind
you all you are in the Bible Belt so
I've been at Houston a thousand times so
what am I supposed to do now am I gonna
go to the [ __ ] Alamo again going out
of that godforsaken I've never even been
in it you know and I'm not talking about
the original Alamo in San Antonio I'm
talking about the Houston Alamo it's a
it's a mom-and-pop place you know I
don't what the [ __ ] I'm talking about I
just want to just say the different city
the wrong city so people could be all
like oh no shaking my head alright let
me read some advertising here for y'all
Felix gray y'all
even if you've never heard of digital
eye strain oh [ __ ] yes oh this is this
is AB yeah okay I remember this one this
is a good one do you never hurt a
digital eye strain chances ah chances
are you've experienced the [ __ ]
effects symptoms like eye fatigue dry
eyes and migraines I'm turning the hose
on your cat all of these things can
happen when you stare at a computer
screen for too long now you can profit
with your eyes now you can post okay now
you can protect your eyes with a
beautifully designed pair of Felix grey
computer glasses I want these things
Felix Gray's lenses are specifically
designed to filter blue light and
eliminate glare from screens the two
main culprits culprits behind digital
eye strain whether you're at work or
play they have the blue light filtering
technology embedded into the lens so
they're effective without the tell
telltale yellow tint or color distortion
of other blue light filtering glasses
Felix Grey's y'all frames are
handcrafted from premium Italian acetate
acetate acetate
I already forget what that means the
same material used by the biggest
designer brands in the world and they're
super stylish there's no prescription
necessary take them out of the box and
slam them on your face and get back to
internet porn their glasses are
available in non prescription readers
and they just launch prescription lenses
so they can so everyone can benefit from
wearing a pair of felix grace all orders
are free shipping and free returns so
you've got nothing to lose go to Felix
grey glasses y'all fel ixg ra y glasses
dot-com slash burr to try a pair of
Felix gray glasses today that's Felix
gray glasses dot-com / / felix great
glasses calm / Berger I think that I
need glasses because of these [ __ ]
computers that and I'm 50
hey I'm 50 y'all let's get in the truck
and go [ __ ] a cat
man butcher box butcher boy I love that
I believe in all the products now
butcher box these these SOPs butcher box
delivers healthy 100% grass-fed in
grass-finished beef free-range organic
chicken and the top shelf the Johnnie
Walker Blue of all meat heritage bread
pork the incredible quality I make my
mouth waters when I read this [ __ ] cuz
all I do is think about that [ __ ] pork
chop I apologize the incredible quality
of butcher box meats stats with the
commitment to raising animals humanely
and free of antibiotics and hormones
before they kill them each box comes
with at least nine to 11 pounds of meat
[ __ ] porn star which is enough for 24
individual sized meals you can choose
from five different box types all beef
beef and chicken beef and pork mix box
custom box lets you choose your own cuts
antibiotic hormone free butcher bucks
believes in healthier food system where
everyone has access to meats the way
nature intended free of antibiotics and
hormones and humanely raised on an open
pasture before we kill them selection
butcher bucks carefully curates the
finest selection and cuts and makes it a
breeze to customize your own delivery
build your own box to get exactly what
you and your family love choose your
delivery frequencies with customized no
subscriptions however you wanted this
recipes are available to put your box
website and videos available to follow
along on butcher blocks YouTube channel
I had the pork it was unbelievable I
loved it
ok anyways it's a lot of words here to
receive free bacon for life the nerve of
Jim Jefferies to say that that this is
not the greatest country of all time
free bacon for life and the good bacon
American bacon not Canadian bacon the
good [ __ ] of Scripps free breaking for
life of subscription what that's wrong
it to receive free bacon for life of
subscription Oh F plus ten dollars off
your order go to butcher
komm click on the big bacon banner on
the homepage and use borough checkout go
now limited time
all right stitch Fitch fix saree stitch
fix stitch fix has reimagined the way we
we find and buy clothes
first of all hats off to these guys no
pun intended that they took the time to
figure out how to fix this boring
problem we've reimagined it like Disney
convenience stitch fix understands that
life gets busy so just tell them your
sizes and your favorite types of clothes
and how much you want to spend and your
personal stylist will pick out your
clothing for you based on your
preferences try before buying if an item
doesn't fit or you just don't like it no
worries just send it back free of charge
style some of us have it some of us
don't but just because a sense of style
seems elusive for some doesn't mean it's
impossible to attain to attain sorry
there's no time like the present to
discover that style you never knew you
had and you can with a little help from
our friends at stitch fix this is like
when they were going to the musical
montage in any 80s movie when they would
like remaking the nerdy chick you know
she wasn't good looking cuz she wore
glasses and had her hair up right then
they'd let the hair down and take the
glasses off it's like oh my god Megan
you're beautiful this is what stitch fix
is gonna do for you stitch fix has
reinvented how we bought finding buy
clothes just answer some basic questions
about your sizes favorite styles and
budget I feel like they already said
this right from your laptop smartphone
or tablet your personalized stylist then
springs into action
Christ I got another order hand
selecting five brand new clothing items
just for you I know I know personal
stylist sounds like something only the
rich and famous can afford but you can
too stitch fix styling fee is only
twenty bucks which is applied as a
credit towards anything you keep and
since your personal stylist uses only
your personal preferences to pick your
clothes
you're still in complete control once
your items have arrived try them on and
pay for what you keep don't like
something need another size just send
the items back gross no questions asked
and shipping is always free both ways
get your fix
wherever you want or sign up to receive
scheduled shipments the choice is yours
you're gonna love stitch fix and what is
it hurry to stitch fix stitch fix calm /
/ to gets tatted now keep all fighting
up 5 items in your box and you'll get
25% off your entire purchase that's
stitch fix calm / / hey stitch fix calm
/ burr alright so anyways I'm on the
road I just ordered a salad and I got
the beef you know probably she got the
chicken I just got fish but a fish
yesterday and you know what I always
forget to tell him don't send me the
[ __ ] dinner rolls and now they got
them all warm underneath the napkin with
some butter and my mother taught me not
to waste so what am I supposed to do
here huh I don't know anyways but I'm uh
I'm liking the way I look right now I
guarantee it so I would like to continue
uh what did not booze in for a while I'm
now gonna do it like the way I smoked
cigars like a chimney
now I'm gonna drink the way I smoke
cigars which is you know once every ten
minutes no once every ten to fourteen
days I have a cigar so I would like to
get hammered or have a couple of
cocktails twice a month that's not bad
twenty four times a year twenty four
times a year I just want to remind my
liver that this is not a game okay the
preseason is over alright so keep your
head on a [ __ ] swivel stay on you
goddamn toast no I got a night coming up
I'm gonna come off the wagon for one day
like what I would like to do come off
the wagon for one day in August and then
I am NOT gonna drink again
until I'm going to a Michigan Wolverine
game this year at the big house Oh
JJ's I have not been to a game there
since 1999 and the only guy there was
some guy in Michigan I believe won the
Heisman and I for some reason I remember
that guy David Boston because he had the
last name Boston and then he went to the
Chargers or something like that I can't
remember but I went to the Michigan Ohio
State game you know the big [ __ ]
rivalry game at the big house that's
that's a good one I've been to some good
ones man I've been to that one I went to
what is it the [ __ ] Texas versus
Oklahoma I've been to that one I never
been to USC UCLA that's [ __ ] I've been
out here for so long but the one I would
love to go to I want to go to Alabama
Auburn I've seen LSU or Alabama I've
seen Texas A&M with Johnny football
first Alabama I just like you know those
[ __ ] SEC games are the best I
shouldn't have said that novelist and
everybody actually the big day I get it
I get you're you're partial to where the
[ __ ] you're from all right that's the
podcast here I got to go do my [ __ ]
show I hope you guys have a wonderful
Thursday and a great weekend you [ __ ]
the music that we're gonna be using is
Darrin King he did a cover of is it
richie haven that his name the guy from
Woodstock he did a cover of his freedom
if you guys want to know who this artist
is Darrin King and he's done everything
used to play drums with mute math he
plays guitar he sings and from what I've
heard he's gonna be maybe doing a small
tour coming up
but I'm a big fan of this guy's just
like incredible artists so enjoy the
music and then we'll have a half hour
greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon
podcast just before Monday from Thursday
and a couple of years ago maybe from
earlier this year I don't know how it
[ __ ] works all right have a great
weekend you cats and I'll see you on
Monday
[Music]
be
I had a great time in Vegas other than
when I went down to the pool cuz I go
down to the pool I'm down there to me
it's [ __ ] j-law head who's been
killing it in front of me and the lovely
Nia and her cousins and we're hang
earning cousin I mean and we're hanging
out down the pool and they're doing the
usual [ __ ] you know if you're a redhead
and you go down to the pool like you
just asking for it people all you know
look out what you are you know like I
never noticed it's like I'm [ __ ]
around myself
I've been around myself since the 60s
the late 60s I know how white I am and
if I ever forget how white I am there's
always somebody there to remind me so I
don't know if you've noticed your skin
tone what am i meditating floating up
out of my body alright so these people
I'm with go come on come on in the pool
I'm like I don't want to go in the pool
I don't want to go in the [ __ ] pool
you know they're like why not why don't
you want to go the pool you know why cuz
the [ __ ] look look at these people
look at them look at them and you're
getting you you know would you take a
bath without with any one of the people
that you see here these [ __ ] just
messes of human beings there's not
enough chlorine and a [ __ ] pool to
kill whatever the [ __ ] they're dragging
in the pool you know it's like I finally
end up going to the pool then everybody
made fun of how white my [ __ ]
alabaster chest was and then I had to
stay in the shade of the [ __ ] in the
lifeguards chair you know you know I had
a show to do I'm being a professional I
can't come out stage later half in the
bag looking like a lobster right I got
to do my little song and dance later on
that night so anyway so I ended up
getting in the [ __ ] pool against my
what I wanted to do you know and then I
get out of the pool first of all for my
age I am in absolutely phenomenal
top-shelf
shape all right I gotta tell you Pete
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] the humanity that I saw poolside in
Las Vegas the [ __ ] humanity keyword
manatee not to skip step on ah Jim
Gaffigan
I just realized he used to use that
reference and I'm pretty sure he used it
I can't remember how the [ __ ] he used it
but if he used it to describe a fat pale
torso not really pale but whatever the
[ __ ] [ __ ] I saw decided that he was
dead on that oh my god is there anything
worse than seeing a tattoo come of age
you know Jesus Christ if you get a
tattoo you better you better just make
the mental decision that you're gonna
p90x for the rest of your [ __ ] life
because when you don't dude I saw this
guy down at the pool all right he had
like not only the worst tattoos you've
ever seen in your life like the worst
placement you know what I mean
like you get one like on the side of
your arm up by your shoulder that looks
good right on the bicep that looks good
you know geo somebody gets one right
over there Voicebox like I don't give a
[ __ ] what you have surrounding that that
leads into that part of the of the work
or the piece whatever they call it looks
[ __ ] horrible leg tattoos horrific
horrific so this [ __ ] jerk-off he has
basically the exact sort of like tribal
thing that the rock has except he
doesn't look tribal he looks like an
accountant you know and he doesn't work
out so just imagine if the rock was his
pasty as I was and it never worked down
in his life but he has that same tattoo
that starts at the elbow goes up the arm
over the shoulder and covers one whole
PEC but the way this guy had it done was
it didn't cover his whole PEC it came
swinging in and went right above is his
man nipple so now all of that all of
that is like
colored-in so because of the paste enos
of his torso your eye is just drawn to
his right nipple is he standing in the
[ __ ] pool my neck was sore from
shaking my head at people it was it was
absolutely [ __ ] horrific right so so
anyways I go back up to the I go back up
to the hotel room right you know gonna
make sure that I'm all shipshape for my
goddamn show and I put on the news and
what do they end up doing a story about
they start doing a story about the
amount of fecal matter found in public
pools right after I just got out of a
goddamn pool you know and I know people
always think oh stay away from where the
kids are stay away from the kiddie pool
right stay away from that they always
blame the [ __ ] kids well I you know
something after seeing what I saw a
poolside you know there weren't a lot of
kids in there but I guarantee you
somebody got a coli I know this is
[ __ ] disgusting but people you you're
basically bathing you know what's even
more [ __ ] up is Vegas is just like you
know people fly in from all over the
world you're taking a [ __ ] AIDS bath
you know with a shot of [ __ ] what the
hell is that [ __ ] that came out but it
killed people so fast that it just
burned out nobody just ran into the
woods the [ __ ] was that [ __ ] called
Christ I can't remember
Ebola that's it
with this shot of a bola or whatever
food poisoning I don't know what it is a
Salmonella shower whatever the [ __ ] you
want to call it I'm done with public
pools the only pool that I will ever
swimming again is my pool if I ever get
one or the pool of some hot chick that I
want a [ __ ] bang because I have Mia's
permission that's the only way it's
gonna go down other than that you know
I'll just go I'll just go take a bath
[Laughter]
that way I'm out of the Sun
you know I'll take a couple of vitamin E
pills whatever the [ __ ] it is you get
from the Sun other than skin cancer I'm
done with it you know what America needs
to implement after years and years of
calling the French people smelly you
know that's kind of like the thing when
we went over to France and save their
ass for the second time last century oh
wait did we do it once we did it one
time right I can't [ __ ] remember
so anyways we've always made fun of the
French finally they smell if you ever
watched Bugs Bunny growing up man you
saw Pepe LePew if you noticed he had a
French accent you know that's the kind
of [ __ ] you couldn't get away with today
because of political correctness I guess
they were basically saying that you know
that they stunk but I'll tell you one
thing well that the French have when it
comes to hygiene over Americans all
right is the bidet all right I can
guarantee you if I ever go swimming in a
public pool again it's going to be in
France unless there's a bunch of
Americans I I've been over to England I
never saw a bidet over there you know
but des is basically a car wash for your
[ __ ] and you know it leaves you
feeling refreshed puts a [ __ ] smile
on your face and evidently in French
you're so [ __ ] happy you forget to
put on deodorant but I'll tell you right
now you can jump in that pool I bet the
next step back they're not talking about
that [ __ ] over there
[Music]
where
hey how are you it's bill burr and it is
the Monday morning podcast for Monday
July 26th 2010 look at that how the last
Monday in July
another summer month flying by and once
again there they are the goddamn banker
[ __ ] just staring you in the face
sticking their hands out their little
grubby [ __ ] hands asking for another
pound of flesh as they do at the end of
every month don't they actually talk to
a buddy of mine who's outside the
business and got to check the other day
right and was you know bitching about
the taxes was talking about all the
taxes taken out and he goes thanks a lot
Obama you know and then I got into a
[ __ ] argument trying to get this dude
to stop blaming the standing [ __ ]
president you got to get to the [ __ ]
guys who put the dude in they're not
even put the dude in there but can take
the dude out you know it doesn't [ __ ]
make a difference I remember I voted for
Ron Paul you know I always vote for
those guys who Ralph Nader's and all
that the Ross Perot's and everybody
always everything I always tells me it's
a [ __ ] waste of a vote is it though
you tell me one [ __ ] thing different
that Obama is doing that McCain wouldn't
be doing I know there's little subtle
differences you know he's gonna rather
than giving it to the [ __ ] rich he's
gonna give it to the [ __ ] poor you
know both their philosophies suck you
know and bankers just keep getting
richer and [ __ ] richer it just it
just blows my mind you know it's one
thing I've learned finally figured out
over all this [ __ ] that whole rich guy
will give it to the rich and they'll
create jobs and it'll trickle down the
key word is trickle and we're all gonna
be sitting there with that tongues I
trying to catch a drop of [ __ ]
prosperity and then on the other side if
you just give people [ __ ] yeah you don't
help them they they come back the next
day like a [ __ ] cat you know waiting
for another bowl
it's like no dude I was trying to give
you nourishment so you could go [ __ ]
you know have enough strength to go milk
a cow whatever the [ __ ] you're supposed
to do I didn't know I thought you were
gonna give a dog this is where I get the
free milk from all right there get the
[ __ ] out of here [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
you know anybody got a I got a got a bum
for a friend always asking for money you
ever do that and you're doing well in
your life and you feel guilty and they
get themselves into a jam and I'm in a
[ __ ] jam you know and it's
everybody's [ __ ] fault but theirs and
their girls got him on the outs and the
cops [ __ ] arrested them and they're
they're gonna put them in [ __ ] jail
you know or whatever's gonna happen
they're gonna take their [ __ ] car and
they need 500 bucks and you [ __ ] give
it to him right and what do you do they
get out of that Jam for [ __ ] ten
minutes and what within a month they're
in another [ __ ] Jam have they learned
anything no and a lot of times it's an
even worse predicament I'm gonna stop
saying Jam like I'm in the [ __ ] 70s
started off me doing the character I'm
in a jam and then I just started saying
it as me and I felt like [ __ ] the
dude who drives the Mystery Machine on
Scooby Doo
ie wouldn't say that he was too much of
a square right [ __ ] the hot chick in
the missionary position am I really
doing Scooby Doo jokes
um the [ __ ] was his name was it Fred
with his Ascot that's all I'm saying
dude it's all [ __ ] [ __ ]
I believe there's plenty of [ __ ]
money if these [ __ ] Bank are [ __ ]
we'll stop taking all of it in these
corporations I don't know does it does
it really cost well it really costs like
[ __ ] 40 bucks a t-shirt if you pay
somebody a decent wage to make it do you
really got to have some eight-year-old
make $3 a [ __ ] day you know isn't
there a [ __ ] middle ground
yeah I don't get it I just don't get it
I just refuse I don't blame politicians
anymore Democrat a Republican I just
don't [ __ ] blame him anymore
it's an absolute it's a [ __ ]
shitstorm look at look at a shitstorm
Obama came walking into that's like yeah
y'all hosting and one of those hoarders
shows and you walk into the house and
it's just piled high with [ __ ] trillions
of [ __ ] things that need to be thrown
out right and then what you give the guy
ten minutes to clean out the [ __ ]
house and then after that it's his mess
look at a [ __ ] mess you made I don't
[ __ ] know I got a I got a met like
politics is just like baseball I stopped
watching in June of last year
you know although I'm starting to come
around again I'm coming back around to
baseball and I'm I'm like in the
Nationals and I'm like in the Pittsburgh
Pirates I'm coming back in through the
[ __ ] backdoor all right going I'm
going down to tier three I'm bored
shitless with Yankees Red Sox I got a
minim [ __ ] burned out I'm burned out
with this [ __ ] it's just like whatever
we won the [ __ ] World Series then we
won another one that's the end of the
movie roll the credits I got a [ __ ]
try to give a [ __ ]
act like I give a [ __ ] twelve times a
goddamn year I don't know yeah but I
don't watch politics either
I just knows all those political [ __ ]
shows on TV I just I can't get into him
because there's nobody really taken the
people that I feel need to be taken to
task and at the end of the day the
people I feel need to be taken to task
are uh it's it's all based on [ __ ] I
watched on YouTube you know so who the
[ __ ] am I to [ __ ] so I just tapped out
I just said you know what [ __ ] it [ __ ]
it I'm gonna get myself a bear you know
maybe get a pistol learn how to shoot
the [ __ ] thing you know what a beer
sounds really good right now
if I ever drank a beer on the [ __ ]
podcast I think I'm gonna think I'm
gonna go [ __ ] get one do I got time to
go run and get it you know what it's not
one of those beers you can really drink
out of a [ __ ] can you got a pour it
into a glass
am I I have the ability to hit pause
don't I I really do
let me see if I know how to do it here
ah Jesus this is always tough do I hit
play do I hit record I hit record
all right and with the magic of the
pause button I am back and I got a
[ __ ] brew right in front of me huh
see this is what I'm doing I don't give
a [ __ ] anymore
I gave a [ __ ] and all you end up doing
it you just start you just start yelling
at people in bars
that's all giving a [ __ ] at you you know
we're gonna make a sign stand on some
street corner honk if you give a [ __ ]
that's that's gonna stop the banks you
can't do it I quit I give up I don't
give a [ __ ] just tell me what to believe
I don't [ __ ] care anymore I want to
get a gun though I really do stand on my
[ __ ] porch waving it at people just
be that guy we always knew he's gonna be
a problem I mean he had a gun I got a
gun too what I'm responsible
I keep it in I keep it in my safe that
way if somebody breaks in I go can you
wait a second I've never understood that
you know it's like if you're gonna have
a [ __ ] gun you know to really protect
yourself don't you have to sleep with it
like [ __ ] Tony Soprano in the
second-to-last episode on The Sopranos
when you thought this Tony Montana
ending was gonna happen and then it
didn't I don't get this you keep it in
the gun safe and then you keep the
bullets in the trunk of your car right
you keep the scope up in the Attic
you know as the intruder is chasing you
around your [ __ ] house you grabbing
different parts of the gun assembling it
stick it under your [ __ ] pillow case
like beretta is that what you're
supposed to do you know what I've never
owned a nightstand in my life I'm gonna
get a gun do this is a I should have
done this on the 4th of July I'm doing a
podcast I'm talking about getting a gun
and I'm drinking a [ __ ] beer and not
one of those [ __ ] ones either he's a
[ __ ] 1 pint Botton's pub ale you know
one of those ones you open it up but
it's got that [ __ ] I don't know what
it has in there that metal ball that
rattles around and you look in you can
never find it you had no idea what it is
but for some reason you never had the
curiosity enough to [ __ ] gut the can
to see what it looks like I like the
mystery I like the mystery of it I don't
know what it is isn't it weird how a
[ __ ] beer like quenches your thirst
and then automatically makes you thirsty
again what's the deal
speaking of guns hope you guys deal if I
just got absolutely shit-faced on this
podcast I feel great I wouldn't even
think that I had a drinking problem I
can just keep hitting pause you guys
wouldn't even know and technically
because I'm talking to you I'm not
drinking alone all right
isn't that what George Thorogood went
off the [ __ ] rails when he did that
song I drink alone loon Rayleigh and he
started putting on the weight and he
still wore those rattlesnake-skin
[ __ ] pants with matching top you know
at some point I mean dude I I should
[ __ ] talk
I should really talk with my [ __ ] my
goddamn I found smooth white belly this
[ __ ] beer at goddamn quarter to 9:00
at night it's not gonna help at least
it's hot is [ __ ] here you know my old
bastard [ __ ] neighbor downstairs his
home you know he like I bring my voice
down
cuz I don't need the [ __ ] I can't
[ __ ] wait you know I got a new
special coming out
rights coming out in September and I got
a feeling this thing's gonna [ __ ] hit
and it's gonna hit hard and I'm finally
gonna go out buy a goddamn house out
here and the day I do when I load up
that [ __ ] you all alright you like
that even though I'm dreaming about
buying a house I'm still a broke [ __ ]
and I have to move my [ __ ] myself when I
load up that you all okay and I bring
that [ __ ] tailgate down one last time
all the way down in that little [ __ ]
[ __ ] little bumper that's only an
inch off the ground to make it easier
for [ __ ] like me to load their Bureau
in there you know I'm gonna ring his
doorbell and I'm gonna get in his face
and be like listen old man I don't know
when I don't know how but I'm gonna
[ __ ] get back I'm gonna do something
to you I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna you know I sound I sound like
[ __ ] jump in Jeff Farmer right now
I'm coming at you full force you turned
the tables on me in the wrong way old
man
no I don't know what I could I can you
know what I don't do the revenge thing I
told you that guys a long time ago I
don't do it you know if I wasn't so
worried that he'd have a heart attack I
really want to scare him one day just do
a fake sneeze right close to him make
him [ __ ] his pants a little bit you know
take a Geritol [ __ ] and his [ __ ]
Dickies miserable bastard really is he's
really the [ __ ] ghost of uh was it
future was that the one that was I don't
know what the [ __ ] he is all right let's
move on here I talked about getting a
gun and so on this is a thing too
because I'm doing this podcast so early
in the week
you know I actually I went through a
bunch of old emails and you know I get a
ton of emails from you guys and and I
know sometimes people get upset when I
don't read them I just get a ton of
emails but I just went back because it's
only Thursday so I didn't really have
that many current ones and I I saw some
gems that I missed and I guess one week
I was talking about the amount of people
that Stalin had killed vers Hitler and
how come people when they bring up evil
they don't talk more about Joseph Stalin
considering it seems to me that he
killed like three times plus a little
bit more I mean what what exactly are
Hitler's exact numbers because I know he
says that they killed six on six million
six hundred Jesus Christ six million
Jewish people but I also know that he
killed gays he killed I think he killed
blacks if they're doing blacks in
Germany
Alex I don't know whatever traders
people who helped out Jewish people I
mean what I mean
did he get another [ __ ] million out
of that I don't know what his exact
number is but I'm pretty safe pretty
safe to say that it's under 10 million
so I was saying like you know Joseph
Joseph Stalin over the [ __ ] he said hey
you know this dis son of a [ __ ] killed
like twice as many of that if you give
Hitler ten million all right so that was
basically what I was riffing on so this
guy I mean this guy made a great point
he actually wrote to me and he said I
ran across something I thought you might
find interesting I know you how you
talked about Hitler versus Mussolini
versus Stalin and the number of deaths
attributed to each one of them well I
don't think they actually did much of
the dirty work they out sourced it to
Indian kids who did it for half the
price ha ha ha that's actually a decent
joke if I read it better seriously they
had it done and they didn't do it
themselves so thinking about the fact
that they didn't do much of the dirty
work got me thinking about who did the
dirty work for themselves after a little
research I came across the person who I
think was the baddest [ __ ] of
World War two
and I loved the suspense he builds up
was he from the US no was he from
Germany ah
was he from England no cigar
[ __ ] was he from Finland Finland
[ __ ] yeah 7 Elias dude was from Finland
the guy's name was and I'm gonna butcher
this cuz even the the phonetic
pronunciation I I don't know how to say
the guys name maybe anybody in Finland
and what's a [ __ ] isn't phys ed Helsinki
I have no [ __ ] idea
Simo hey ha I don't know the [ __ ] to say
it my best attempt at the pronunciation
of the last name is
What did he say how ha has an Hat hat
how ha Simo how hair I don't know
anyways he was nicknamed white death due
to the fact that he would operate in the
snow and had a completely white uniform
so he couldn't be seen
alright let's let's go onto the
Wikipedia let me read about this guy the
first thing you know if you look at look
look this guy up it's si mo H a Y H a
lived to be 96 years old all right
nicknamed the white death by the
Russians his highest recorded number of
kills he was a sniper was 505 he has the
highest recorded number of kills 505
kills in any major war all right before
entering combat he was a farmer and a
hunter his farmhouse was reportedly full
of trophies for marksmanship so I guess
he was a natural he was kind of like the
Wayne Gretzky of killing [ __ ] right
it was during war the world the Winter
War 1939 to 1940 between Finland and the
Soviet Union isn't anagen interesting
they call it the Winter War well maybe
that was an aspect of World War 2 I have
no idea anyways the Winter War that he
began his duty as a sniper and fought
for the Finnish army against the Red
Army in temperatures of minus 40 and
minus 20 degrees Celsius so what's that
like 80 degrees Fahrenheit have no idea
[ __ ] cold out dressed completely in
white camouflage hey ha whatever the
[ __ ] he calls name hey yeah was credited
with 505 confirmed kills of Soviet
soldiers 540 to unconformity the
unofficial finished frontline figure
with the battle battlefield of Cola
places the number of his kills at over
800 because I guess he also had a
submachine gun and people give him
credit for killing another 200 people
thus
bringing his credits up to at least 705
remarkably this is the biggest thing
here this [ __ ] did this in fewer
than a hundred days with very limited
amount of daylight per day so he just
sort of woke up I guess you know he's
killing like seven people a day he's up
for 16 hours once every couple hours uh
what else could I say about this guy I
missed the part where he got deformed
part of the way through there he was
[ __ ] is in another tactic hey how was to
compact the snow you would compact the
snow in front of him so that the shot
wouldn't disturb the snow and reveal his
position he also kept snow in his mouth
so that when breathing this steam would
not give him away
how have they not made a movie about
this guy he prefer to use iron sights
rather than telescopic sights for all
you gun nuts to present a smaller target
oh I see cuz the sniper must raise his
head higher when using a telescopic
sight to prevent visibility risk a
telescopic sights glass can fog up
easily okay the Soviets tried a number
of ways to get rid of him
countersnipers artillery strikes and
finally on May 6 the guy was shot
through the jaw during combat by a
Russian soldier the the bullet tumbled
upon impact and left his head fellow
soldier picked him up half his head was
missing he regained consciousness seven
days later the day peace was declared
shortly after the war
this dude was went straight from
corporal to second lieutenant the
highest jump in rank in the history of
the Finnish army Wow did that boy how
that gun didn't bore you guys too much
but uh there you go
and they asked him later on in life that
did it bother you the amount of people
that you kill which is such a douchey
[ __ ] question and he just basically
said look I was doing the job he told me
to do like they all end up [ __ ]
saying did it bother you did it bother
me that I killed the guys who were
trying to kill me no it didn't
I'm sure a couple of dumb [ __ ] who
thought they were in the clear and got
up and took a piss you know and he kind
of felt bad like Jesus Christ do
Keeley's piss behind a tree you know
maybe that wouldn't make you feel bad
what do you guys think do you think
you'd feel bad
I would just think if I went to war I've
always felt this that the second the
battle started I would be I would be the
guy crying in the foxhole but if I could
ever just kill that first [ __ ] person
I would just be like all right well you
know [ __ ] it now and I just think I
would be so filled with anger and fear
that I don't know I don't know that's
and I have no [ __ ] you know those
people who fight in wars man people are
joined the service Jesus Christ I I
don't know I don't think I could you
know as much as people sit there and
they talk about you know the balls it
takes to do stand-up you know it really
pales in [ __ ] comparison when you
know if you just talk about someone who
goes into the Peace Corps and is trying
to bring water to a tribe forget about
somebody's [ __ ] going to war and
speaking of let's talk about stand-up
terminology here's something that has
been bugging me lately is I've noticed
that and this happens you know people
come up with new words like you know I'm
chilling I'm gonna use like hip-hop
slang cuz that's always the easiest you
know what I hear that someone's I can
really think of and then they just
become words but just as is it as a
stand-up comic purist I've noticed you
know when I get into it with the crowd
when somebody heckles me and then I give
him [ __ ] back I get emails I was at your
second show sat on Saturday night I
loved the way you heckled that guy in
the audience after he heckled you
heckling is done by the crowd the
comedian does not heckle the crowd he
can play with the crowd and he can
[ __ ] I don't even know what it's
called when when you [ __ ] murderer a
heckler you destroy him but you're not
heckling him all right you're up there
trying to do your rack the only way for
a comedian to heckle a crowd as if he if
he sat in the crowd in the hope in the
whole crowd got up onstage and then
tried to do something to some sort of
performance and I interrupted and [ __ ]
up their performance
but when they tell me to go [ __ ]
themselves [ __ ] myself they're not
heckling me Jesus you would think that I
would actually have the decency to look
up heckle why don't I do the heckle
definition god damn it that beer tasted
good and I get a [ __ ] 654 am
definition for heckle okay here we go
trying to embarrass and annoy by
questions jives or objections badger try
to annoy someone speaking or performing
in public by questions jibes or
objections and bad there you go see
that's why you can't because you're not
trying to perform in public all right I
skipped over the [ __ ] in parentheses so
let me read that again try to heckling
is trying to embarrass n annoy someone's
speaking or performing in public by
questions jives or objections badger or
whatever that's what it means so the
comedian can't heckle the crowd because
the crowd is not on stage trying to give
a performance so for the love of God
stop sending me [ __ ] emails saying
you loved how I heckled the crowd I
didn't do that it's like telling a
guitarist I love you drum solo do they
make any sense is this alcohol taking PI
haven't drank
I haven't [ __ ] ate in a minute you
know this beer is [ __ ] delicious you
know what makes a beer like this tastes
good a good beer glass do you guys have
beer glasses talking to the men out
there and a few women out there who are
[ __ ] you guys women aren't into beer
glasses are you you know driving
lesbians on my podcast maybe you guys
have the brains to like beer glasses
Jesus Christ now you know I usually
don't make any sense but me buzz doing
this podcast is gonna make even less and
less sense that's a [ __ ] sign of
maturity of beer glass and that's
another thing if you want to stave off
the fact that you kind of think that you
have a drinking problem is if in your
house if you have the proper glasses for
whatever alcohol you're drinking okay
you're drinking whiskey out of a Dixie
cup
stuttering like a [ __ ] that was a
good line too if you're drinking whiskey
out of a Dixie cup take two yeah there's
really no way you know little vodka in a
sippy cup your kids crying in the corner
because he's [ __ ] hungry hey Paul let
me call you back I'm doing my podcast
all right I might take it easy all right
where the [ __ ] am i yeah you know what I
mean but if you have the right you have
the proper glass I have the classic
16-ounce you know you'd pour a Heineken
in this type of thing I actually got
those Sam Adams glasses too you know the
ones that they had where they got some
sort of special glass thing at the
bottom and it makes the beer you know
the same add and swirl up there really
cool glasses but what I don't like is
they only hold 12 ounces you know and
it's just like well what about me who
likes to go 16 ounces at a time you know
all right I'm not even being funny right
now I'm just [ __ ] sitting here
enjoying there's nothing better one nice
[ __ ] beer but can you ever stop you
know as funny as my girl's not here
right now here be funny if I'm just
sitting here my [ __ ] boxers and just
just she comes home and I've already go
on the road for another five days and
then she just comes home and I'm just
[ __ ] sitting here buzzed you know
t-shirt boxers socks I mean I'm just
dressed like I'm unemployed then all I
got to do is just start giving a [ __ ]
why am i such a dick
all right let's continue on here yeah
that would be unsightly and now speaking
of [ __ ] that's just [ __ ] unsightly to
use a segue from the 1980s I was flying
back from New York and you know it's a
real pet bait pet peeve of mine is these
these [ __ ] like regular looking
people
just get here they kicked their shoes
off during the flight all right and
they're not wearing any socks all right
so it's gross enough that you have your
bare feet on that airline carpet where
god knows what is in the rug okay you
know how filthy the [ __ ] air is in
the goddamn tube they never recycle that
[ __ ] air you're just breathing I mean
it's like 80% carbon dioxide right so
what the [ __ ] you think is in the rug
have you ever seen him shampoo a goddamn
rug in between flights they don't do it
and you're putting your bare feet on and
that's what kills me this is regular
[ __ ] people after after they've
kicked the shoes off they have to go to
the bathroom they get up and they they
walk down the aisle into the bathroom
with no [ __ ] socks or shoes on it's
the most disgusting I saw this girl
sitting next to me she had one of those
English Australian I can't pick out the
accent you know the next time you
[ __ ] European [ __ ] on what animals we
are over here one of your [ __ ] when
are you [ __ ] Birds who was sitting
next to me got up with their flip-flops
on no kicked them off and then well she
actually I'll give her credit she did
walk halfway to the bathroom and then
came back you know and I was like all
right she has some class but she had her
hair up and she had flakes behind her
ear was disgusting the whole [ __ ]
flight and I couldn't stop looking at
every time I glanced over and then I
would just keep making these noises
going up ah then she sort of glanced at
me and I pretend like I didn't do it she
probably thought I had Tourette's and
she didn't realize that I'm reacting to
the [ __ ] [ __ ] flakes behind here
kind of a mother are you gonna be you
can't even clean behind your own [ __ ]
ears put your head down and go walk
barefoot to the [ __ ] airplane goddamn
bathroom and clean yourself up before I
slap the [ __ ] out of you alright what
else do we got here alright here's a
good YouTube video for the week as the
[ __ ] booze is starting to kick in
Boddingtons I highly recommend it
alright you youngsters out there you're
probably not going to like it
all right but as your voice gets deeper
and your balls start to drop even
further into the toilet bowl I'm telling
you it's a beer you're gonna [ __ ] like
what am I doing here where the hell am i
all right
note to self don't drink when you do the
podcast anymore would you would you guys
enjoy a podcast so I just got completely
shit-faced the thing is is it's only an
hour long so it's kind of hard to get
drunk that quick I get pretty buzzed you
know really bill is that what we're here
we're down to right now is like you're
gonna do like some [ __ ] stunt like
David Blaine bill once you do the
podcast and a [ __ ] block of ice you
dumb [ __ ] I think it's time for a
special guest at some Pillai got I got
to get another special guest on this
podcast um all right plowing ahead here
um here's a YouTube video to watch for
this week
baby preacher with subtitles ah it's
just [ __ ] awesome it's a I don't know
this baby who I guess is goes to church
every [ __ ] day and has watched these
preachers preaching and then they gave
the baby to Mike and it's just sort of
walking around good yeah
talking baby talk but somebody
transcribes what the kid is saying and i
swear to god it the way they put it up
there it right as you read it the baby
says it and it sounds like the babies
saying and it's [ __ ] and it's a
visual joke and I'm trying to explain it
here all right underrated overrated for
this week I'm doing this at a half hour
in knowing full well that I have to
somehow fill up another 20 [ __ ]
minutes all right overrated for this
week this is a great one overrated wind
chimes this dude says I hate the
annoying clink Clank sound with a
[ __ ] passion what is wrong with the
people huh
what's wrong with people seriously the
world is not loud enough you have to
[ __ ] add to it you know they they do
believe the sounds will make them better
people or make life better you know what
dude you want such a great role - you're
right bro that [ __ ] sentence oh do
they believe the sounds will make them
better people or make their life better
I found it most annoying and invasive
I find it thought Jesus Christ I'm never
drinking on the podcast again go [ __ ]
yourselves
alright what is wrong with people where
may I find it the most annoying and
evasive thing I am forced to listen to
even with closed windows but they're so
peaceful if you [ __ ] like the sound
why don't you put them up inside your
home and have the [ __ ] fan going and
anyway what gives anybody the right to
push their tastes on others dude I
totally agree it's like if you're gonna
make smokers smoke outside then you want
to make these [ __ ] wind chime people
take that [ __ ] indoors I can't tell you
how annoying that is
it's an you know what's annoying about
it is it's an annoying sound that's
trying to be [ __ ] spiritual that's
what kills me
it's even a it's more annoying than just
a loud annoying sound that's [ __ ]
annoying because at least the loud
annoying sound has the [ __ ] courage
to be annoying those [ __ ] things they
actually they're there they're there you
know when I go on YouTube and just get
some [ __ ] wind chime sounds for all
you've done [ __ ] out there who do yoga
you know and actually think that these
[ __ ] things sound good here we go
wind [ __ ] chimes YouTube let's see
what we got here we go yeah cuz somebody
[ __ ] loves them so much they put up a
video here we go for all you [ __ ] out
there here it is
[Music]
I gotta admit those are nice this isn't
fair this guy's got [ __ ] he's got the
professional grade level ones these
things look like the exhaust on a
goddamn well that's giant wind chimes
all right I just learned something
I don't mind giant wind chimes all
here's one here's one of these a little
douchey once you get in a [ __ ]
hardware store
typical YouTube you just can't put
windchimes out there barely a beautiful
wind chime it's just the Kunti sunny one
[Music]
there it is you know what the great
thing is is they're made out of metal so
when you rip them off you have a [ __ ]
blunt object to beat your neighbor to
death with that's what you do and then
you dip it in [ __ ] peroxide or bleach
and you hook it back up again
let those ane [ __ ] figure out that
murder LeMay and murdered on his porch
you know somehow they find you know in a
[ __ ] I don't know an eighth of an
inch of his face imprint on that [ __ ]
wind chime if you ever watch those ane
things how they catch people it's it's
like it's not even [ __ ] fair you ever
see the one as they take another healthy
sweater I Got News for you I'm having
another beer this might be the new thing
I might do this [ __ ] Thursday night take
a night off from stand-up tell my chick
to hit the [ __ ] bricks cuz anything
better than drinking your own goddamn
house it just makes you want to start
screaming about the [ __ ] you own you
know I paid for this [ __ ] you hear that
old man downstairs I'm gonna get louder
and he's gonna come up here that would
be the ultimate podcast you know
anything about old people is you always
have to worry that they are a [ __ ]
like they fought in a [ __ ] war cuz I
never had I never have so I have total
respect for [ __ ] veterans and the
fact that they still got it in him you
know that would be insane one night if I
actually just totally pissed him off and
he really did fight in the Korean War
and he just [ __ ] threw whatever that
[ __ ] thing is you throw up when you
when are you gonna climb up the rope on
the side of the building you know that
that dead [ __ ] land fishhook thing
throws it up there and just climbs up
comes over my railing as I'm sitting
here doing this podcast half in the bag
and he's got a kitchen knife between his
teeth like a [ __ ] pirate what would I
do
I probably
taking 12 karate classes in my life and
they've all been like you know six years
apart [ __ ] guy coming in fillet me
you know I don't [ __ ] know I just sat
back and I just lost the screen here
yeah so whatever wind chimes are [ __ ]
overrated
they really are but I got to tell you if
you get the giant ones the giant ones a
nice listen to the giant ones the giant
ones have a nice tone to them it's a
little deeper I think I figured it out
[Music]
come on man you gotta MIT that's not bad
if you like over the anger your
childhood right let go your anger for a
second
see sound of a ship in the background
[Music]
the ocean coming up on the beach you
ever get to that point right when you're
gonna get relaxed and let go and then
you get so [ __ ] scared you get right
back into the anger and then you want to
punch somebody in [ __ ] yoga pants um
all right enough with the [ __ ] wind
shams here
I was really painting a picture they're
[ __ ] Michael Winslow here I think
it's time for more booze what do you
guys think how about a nice healthy sip
ah goddamn it
that's [ __ ] delicious he pulled
bastards an Owen Owen a you pull past
it's an a a that was one good thing
about the trip when I went back has
actually got to do opening Anthony and
I'm gonna do it again next week probably
again the Tuesday again I'm on the exact
same flight back to Los Angeles I did it
the Opie and Anthony show this past
Tuesday popped in there for like an hour
had a good [ __ ] time didn't get a
chance to argue with Anthony but you
know it's still good to see him as
adorable as ever all right let's uh
let's plow ahead here let's get to some
more [ __ ] overrated [ __ ] overrated
super expensive TVs who the [ __ ] needs
to spend two grand on a TV I know the
Super Clear etc but it's not like it's
it's some huge jump my eight year old
Sony still works great the picture is
fine if I want to watch some great TV
I'll just go to one of the hundred bars
in the city that have 80 of them slapped
on the walls which another thing which
is another thing that's overrated
cookie-cutter bars with a million TVs
and zero atmosphere but I digress you
guys why you guys have [ __ ] good
writers and I like how you said I
digress rather than me last week when I
say but I digressed in the past tense
that's because I never used that
expression and I'm a [ __ ] dude I have
to totally agree with you in fact I
would still have an old-school TV if
um I didn't move from New York New York
to LA I was gonna keep my old school one
I had no problem watching the game on
the old school square TV it didn't bug
me you know I don't need to see that the
inside of shacks I don't need to see
shacks [ __ ] you know nose cartilage
every when I first got HGTV I was
watching I was watching ESPN and like
Stewart's car to one of those guys is
doing it and I'm like looking at his
pores and I could see actually a little
bit of the inside of his nose this nose
wasn't dirty or nothing but it was just
it's like dude all I need it's just to
hear the scores I'll tell you no it's
[ __ ] overrated too and I hope it
flops like [ __ ] David Beckham in LA
or here's one great overrated is [ __ ]
[ __ ] in 3d all right
avatar and 3d who gives a [ __ ] some
butterfly flying near your face your
goddamn fairy the [ __ ] is wrong with you
and all these idiots who are gonna go
out and buy 3d TVs you dumb [ __ ] if you
buy a 3d TV you know what you like you
like those do you like one of those dumb
shits who keeps buying the new razor
blades has any razor blade work better
than the [ __ ] all you needed was to
one sucked to was the [ __ ] three doesn't
do underneath you knows you got to pinch
your nose like you're in a barbershop in
the 19 [ __ ] 20s getting a straight
razor shave during a [ __ ] Three
Stooges film and then it goes all the
way up to four and then they knew they
couldn't do five or did they do five and
now they're trying to act like the
blades are even [ __ ] sharper it's all
[ __ ] the worst thing that ever
happened to me one time I was doing a
college or something I think I was in
Florida and it was the double whammy
I had a toiletry bag
from tough crowd one of my favorite
[ __ ] shows to do tough crowd with
Colin Quinn and one of the one of the
the gift bags they gave you it was was
this this toiletry bag it's a tough
crowd on it and [ __ ] you know and not
only did I leave that forgot it in the
bathroom but my my razor my twin bladed
razor was in it and they don't sell them
anymore and ever since then I've had the
triple one and it just sucks hey if
there's one whisker right in that better
skin between your [ __ ] nostrils I
can't get it I can't get it and I got to
do all these different [ __ ] tricks
I'm doing it right now you just I gotta
like you know make my nose look like
that [ __ ] chicks nose in the batman
revenge movie um i bet she has no
problem i was kind of mean yeah so you
guys do me a favor all right
don't buy it don't buy 3d tvs don't
[ __ ] buy him okay two-dimensional
football is still the [ __ ] are you
really gonna sit there on the couch with
your friend wearing those stupid [ __ ]
glasses
so what Tio's balls can be in your face
come on you want to see it in 3d go to
the [ __ ] game now watch the tvs will
be awesome the TV's will be awesome and
eventually I'll get I mean if you guys
notice what a [ __ ] hypocrite I am
about the Prius I defended it and slowly
I'm going towards a challenger you know
I'm [ __ ] totally into conspiracy
theory I'm actually still into that [ __ ]
and I don't give a [ __ ] now I'm just
sitting here in my underwear doing a
podcast on Thursday drinking a beer you
know I quit [ __ ] quit you know I
realize the other day too is you don't
want ever yet you start talking [ __ ]
when you get into conspiracy theory you
actually think that like you know you're
you're onto something dangerous and
people are gonna start watching you but
the bottom line is is the second you
recorded it and there's you know I just
look at what Mel Gibson is going through
what he's going through with the
recorded [ __ ] that he's [ __ ]
said I'm not saying I said anything
racist or anything but everything that
I've done in the podcast in the last
three [ __ ] years I could never pull a
Schwarzenegger let's just [ __ ] just
like totally get into fantasy here let's
pretend that I actually somehow became a
huge [ __ ] movie star did it for 20
years and then got sick of it and
decided to run for political office you
could pick any one of my podcasts and
that would be the end of the campaign
you know especially those ones early on
when I said [ __ ] every other [ __ ]
word I just I go through phases I didn't
I get into golf for a minute I got a
conspiracy theory for a minute I got
into saying [ __ ] for a minute
and I don't know it just all goes by the
[ __ ] wayside this is one of the
reasons why I can't sustain a [ __ ]
relationship although I've been able to
sustain this one you know I finally
realized I'm gonna stop [ __ ] running
like that [ __ ] Eagle song that's
stupid song desperado you know I would
like to do that I would like to do a
Three Stooges slap to everybody in the
Eagles is greater of musicians that they
are those cheeseball songs that they
wrote desperado why don't you come to
your senses
shut up Don Henley just play the [ __ ]
drums why don't you make a good [ __ ]
song this song is a class yeah I wanted
what the [ __ ] Who am I kidding I'd love
to be making the [ __ ] Bank those guys
are making you know I'm gonna warn you
guys when I make some [ __ ] money in
this business I'm gonna sell out like
you've never seen anybody sell out and
your [ __ ] life I don't know what I'm
gonna do but I'm gonna tap out I know I
am I'm gonna buy a modest house in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere I was actually
looking at property in like Wyoming and
Montana I'm getting into that [ __ ]
having a [ __ ] ranch a couple of
[ __ ] yaks goddamn pig that you can
boot in the ass when your well water
isn't coming up that day
[ __ ] [ __ ] ain't working thing running
over the hill
who's gonna report you you're out there
by yourself dude you live in [ __ ]
Wyoming a Montana you get yourself a
spread you know you - it's like you have
your own country just walk around naked
on your property nothing but you and
your [ __ ] timberlands just shoot and
[ __ ] slowly going crazy best friends
with like a pheasant you know I [ __ ]
love it
learn how to grow [ __ ] vegetables and
[ __ ] you want to stand that how [ __ ]
awesome that would be because I'll still
do stand-up just listen to this this is
the [ __ ] dream that for some reason
this week I'm totally into I'm gonna
live like that and then every other week
I get to leave the Ponderosa and then I
fly into a [ __ ] metropolis alright
get this you know hang out with
everybody who's living on top of one
another
you know soak up that vibe for a minute
hanging next today go to a football game
you know eat somebody's barbecue that
they claim is the greatest but it's
always some dried out [ __ ] ribs and
chicken with some sweet sauce the sauce
always tastes the best the meat always
sucks you know once again I had some
more smoked [ __ ] barbecue and I
whatever the hell it is I always eat it
I always believe like this is gonna be
the one that's gonna make me like it
anyways nah dude I would love to [ __ ]
do that [ __ ] I don't know if I could do
it I don't know if I could live way out
in the middle of nowhere
but I'm telling you that that really the
the longer I'm in this business and the
longer I'm on flights and I'm sitting
next to people with [ __ ] flakes
behind their ears and they're getting up
and they're walking to the bathroom
without their [ __ ] shoes on and I'm
listening to the male stewardess on the
mic we have a very full flight you know
if it can feet if it can feet if they
can fit in the seat in front of you
please be courteous other people on the
flight and they never are
they never are people up there just
stick and [ __ ] they can easily fit in
front of the seat in front of them and I
swear to god they'll be like John Denver
I'll learn how to fly a plane and buy
some experimental [ __ ] thing and
crash it in the side of a mount that's
the thing though that's that's the
ultimate right there that I'll tell you
right now if you guys want to know what
it's like to do the [ __ ] road and I'm
telling you right now I know salesmen
and people with corporate jobs who have
to fly around the country what you do
after a while is you fantasize about the
way you want to do the road if you could
do the [ __ ] road and I would love it
like I don't know if I could live in
[ __ ] in the middle of nowhere like that
but let's just say I could so this would
be the deal I live in the middle of
nowhere on the [ __ ] Ponderosa right
wood-burning stove it's it's like it's a
[ __ ] log cabin but you still got the
flatscreen I'll build a [ __ ] ice rink
out back for the kids that I don't have
you know have like four [ __ ] dogs cuz
who gives a [ __ ] you could buy a mansion
for like 1,200 bucks out there have like
four [ __ ] dogs
keek I get got Cleo
I'll get a [ __ ] okay pitbull a boxer
a [ __ ] bulldog and then what else I
get a mutt I mean he a bloodhound
yeah something likes to howl but also
likes to lay around you know
do my MTV Cribs and rather than have a
bunch of [ __ ] cars I'll have the
baddest of the Lamborghini the Ferrari
the Porsche and the [ __ ] Dodge
Challenger at dogs right lining them up
in my [ __ ] dirt driveway you know and
then down the street somehow I'd have my
own pride this is this is the ultimate
right I got my own [ __ ] private jet
Oh meanwhile the business is also
sending me [ __ ] movie scripts just
offer me begging me begging me not only
to be in the movie
but all I gotta be is like the [ __ ]
six the lead and when I show up they
shoot all my [ __ ] you know you have me
for five days shoot all my [ __ ]
scenes and I'm that guy who was in the
movie like [ __ ] three four times but
kills it so I keep my career going this
is the dream then I live in the middle
of nowhere I [ __ ] make my [ __ ] got
my garden in the back fresh vegetables
got a chicken coop every once in a while
who wants a [ __ ] burrito hang on a
second I'm gonna go ring the neck of
something you grab it and you [ __ ] by
the neck here's how you do it you grab
by their neck and then you spin their
[ __ ] body around and that's it all
right you have your oldest son named
John Boy and you have him pluck the [ __ ]
you stick it in the Senate and forget it
you kept it as a joke as a reminder of
civilization you [ __ ] eat that way
and then whenever I got a gig I go down
the [ __ ] Street down the street
whatever rural road number forty-seven
and then there's a [ __ ] Airport I got
my own jet and pilots on call all right
and in the back of the plane that's just
a big goddamn bed with a huge [ __ ]
seat belt and they [ __ ] knock me out
if it's a long flight if it isn't I just
sit there shooting this [ __ ] with the
pilots and that's what I do then I fly
in I do the gig and then I [ __ ] go to
a sporting event then I fly back that's
my [ __ ] dream that's my dream of how
I'd like to do the road how do you like
that
huh booze is good on the podcast isn't
it I hope I'm not going to listen back
to this
I'm not buzzed and think that this is
[ __ ] up but that's something I would
like to do but I gotta be honest I don't
think that I could live in Wyoming on
Montana I do think that I could live
where could I live I could live in parts
of Pennsylvania Connecticut upstate New
York
parts of northern New Jersey
maybe Western Massachusetts
I don't know maybe Northern California
we get up there and they got some
redwoods and [ __ ] I know that's [ __ ]
up man
it's scary you want to do something
[ __ ] up go uh go on go on Google Maps
and just just look at Montana and then
just pick pick a town and then hit
satellite and then just you know drop
that little man and then just go down a
[ __ ] Street and you'll see what it's
like out there you know and if you don't
hear banjo music you're not a [ __ ]
human being it's scary
I'd love to go out there man I want to
check it out you know just see what the
[ __ ] is going on up there actually no
guy who has a gig out in [ __ ] Montana
I've actually was thinking about doing
it just cuz I've never been never been
out that way
alright let's get on with the overrated
underrated now or continue with it I
should say
do overrated the word I like this one
overrated the use of the word countless
I hear it on the news all the time this
tragedy has left countless numbers of
people homeless that's [ __ ] I think
there are like six or seven billion
people on earth I know the numeric
system works I can count to seven
billion hell I could count to seven
trillion given enough time I'm not
saying the tragedies that happen aren't
bad but trying to jack up the fear
quotient by making it sound like the
number of people affected is just too
big to comprehend is [ __ ] I like
that I never noticed that leaving
countless people homeless what do you
mean by the actually 1247 well you know
what I think I could count that high are
you saying that you don't care about the
homeless no you dumb [ __ ] I'm saying
that I can count that high so it's not
countless twelve hundred is its
countable leaving countable people
homeless
this guy's absolutely right or this
woman whoever wrote it in absolutely
[ __ ] right you are absolutely [ __ ]
correct on that one underrated animated
shows on TV today The Simpsons
and Family Guy are legitimately well
done shows and Southpark to a lesser
degree dude I think South Park is still
the best
I'd go South Park the Simpsons and then
the family guy South Park has the best
social commentary on TV but I have to
tell you this I don't watch that show
what the [ __ ] is it I always mean to
watch it it comes on Sunday night the
how the [ __ ] do I describe it it's the
African American one there we go come on
you know it I don't know what it is but
I heard that one is the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is the name of it I can't remember
I heard that one's awesome I got to get
into watching that I always say I'm
going to and then I never do and there's
also a billboard I've seen on Sunset
Boulevard out here for that show
Children's Hospital it looks creepy as
hell and it's on Adult Swim that's what
I'm trying to say Adult Swim it is is
what that other the boondocks right is
that the name of it and there's the I
heard that Children's Hospital is great
I want to check that one out too
alright okay cartoons I they have good
writing good plot points and legitimate
social commentary totally agree on all
of that this is what pisses me off
though I can tell you that the number of
times that someone will ask me what I've
watched on television I will give them
the plot of a Simpsons episode not
mentioning any names or the fact that
it's a cartoon and they will tell me how
funny they think it is
but then when I tell them it's the
Simpsons of the Family Guy it's a
Simpson or a Family Guy episode all of a
sudden they turn their noses up and say
that they're adults and they don't watch
cartoons anymore
what the [ __ ] is up with that a funny
show is a funny show dude I couldn't
agree with more I couldn't agree with
you more
let me take the last [ __ ] swig here
and I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna finish
this thing off and I want to finish up
the podcast here's something that I have
learned on on the podcast hang on a
second here we go let me get a little
more a little more happy juice here
oh god damn it that's [ __ ] perfect um
anyways oh by the way I've been watching
a lot of the old Jackie Gleason
I so watch him when I was a kid and I
never really noticed how many the the
older shows it was weird I don't know
what it was because I came up in the 70s
you have to understand that a lot of the
original shows weren't filmed so there
was no syndication that was the
brilliance of Ricky Ricardo there what's
his face there Ricky Ricardo's his
character name Desi Arnaz that he
actually had the brilliance to film I
love you I Love Lucy and get the rights
for the old episodes like nobody in the
business foresaw the money in reruns and
they just they signed off and just gave
them to him basically for [ __ ]
nothing
so anyways it wasn't a lot of reruns
certainly from the 1950s there's you
know a lot of those live shows they just
went live and that was it but so like
what am I trying to say and actually
television well this how old I am
television for the most part as far as
the golden age of television right up
was only 20 years old and there was only
three networks so you basically got the
best of the best and I used to watch
like the Jackie Gleason show they used
to show reruns of the Dean Martin show I
know this makes me sound like I'm older
than [ __ ] dirt but they used to play
it they used to play all that [ __ ] Three
Stooges all that type of [ __ ] and I used
to watch the Jackie Gleason show and he
had this character Reginald van Gleason
and I don't know the character he just
had this little broom mustache and
before he would say anything he would
come sort of hum mmm and then say
whatever he said and I watched one the
other day where he was playing he's
trying to solve a murder mystery and he
comes walking in on this couple there's
a dead body in there and but before he
starts questioning him about the murder
he actually sees a wet bar so he just
puts his index finger up this way I'd
loved about Jackie Gleason was how
without saying anything he could go for
like you know minutes on end without
saying anything and just have you die in
laughing and he in and he never
rehearsed either and he just fight he
puts his finger up and after he sees the
bar and he walks over to the wet bar and
he does all this exaggerated [ __ ] of
making the drink but before he walks
with the second he's of explaining this
wrong whatever he comes walking over to
the bar the second he sees it he just
goes mmm booze right and it gets this
[ __ ] laugh I don't know I don't know
I just love that old-school [ __ ] we're
[ __ ] drinking and having a drinking
problem is funny this guy there's a dead
body in the room and he's gonna make
himself a drink first he obviously has
he's pre-op priorities around a [ __ ]
whack and nobody gives a [ __ ] so
whatever but anyways this last week of
this podcast I really learned man how to
do if I ever want to do a [ __ ] radio
show there's three there's three topics
that get me the most email responses of
either I totally agree with you or
you're [ __ ] annoying the [ __ ] out of
me and they are politics sports and in
Jesus or any sort of religion if I go
off on any of those like you know
trashing the [ __ ] LeBron I'm trashing
what did I do a few weeks ago I trashed
New York and the Knicks I got all these
[ __ ] emails from Knicks fans you know
last week I trashed the [ __ ] I didn't
think I trashed the Lakers I thought I
was just talking about Kobe versus
Jordan but all these [ __ ] Laker fans
just [ __ ] writing in writing and
capital letters flipping the [ __ ] out
and I don't know this podcast has been
very educational in like in like that
level where it's like if I ever do a
[ __ ] radio show which I don't think I
will I like doing this [ __ ] better and I
always felt when I did uninformed when
we were actually able to do episodes of
that I always felt the callers
slowed-down the show you know know so
many people just [ __ ] with you or
whatever but if I ever get a situation I
have to do a radio show and I want to
get callers those are the three [ __ ]
magic topics that just get people
flipping the [ __ ] out I guess the fourth
would be if you if you trash one of the
sexes you know I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm saying here I'm just enjoying
the nice buzz of one [ __ ] beer that's
a great thing to do drink up drink a
16-ounce really good beer on an empty
[ __ ] stomach you know and do a
goddamn podcast and tell me you're not
proud to be a [ __ ] American all right
that's it okay I think we had a little
bit of something for everybody here wind
chimes booze reminiscing telling you my
dreams of how I want to live in the
[ __ ] future I guess none of which
included having a spouse or children
[ __ ] creepy as that ah that's it
that's the podcast here that I did it on
a Thursday and hopefully I'm gonna try
to do Letterman again next week my set
is more than ready to go and I'll try to
give you the heads up this time if I if
I get bumped um but whatever it's
actually I actually I'm kind of psyched
that I got bumped cuz there's nothing
cooler than going to the Ed Sullivan
Theater it's just a [ __ ] and you just
come out beforehand they show you where
your mark is and as much as they're
showing you where your mark is you sit
sitting there God Jesus Christ the
[ __ ] Beatles were here
the stones were here the doors came as
where the doors came out and and and Jim
Morrison whatever the [ __ ] he wasn't
supposed to say he said it's incredible
it's an incredible uh
it's one of the few things left in show
business that is still as big as show
business was back in a day before it all
that's splintered into like 400 400
different channels so whatever all you
young comics out there would never done
let them and I'm telling you it's not
gonna [ __ ] disappoint you it's it's a
huge thrill this is my fifth time doing
it I'm beyond excited and I'm really
hoping I get to get on this weekend
that's it that's the podcast for this
week I hope all you guys enjoyed it and
I will talk to you next week okay
[Music]
we